now listen voters in the UK the EU and
across the developed world this is a
call to action we need you to contact
your heads of state to tell them not to
sign the UN Global compact for migration
UK get your heads out of the brexit
shambles for a few minutes and listen on
the 10th and 11th of December our heads
of state will be signing this deeply
damaging document produced by those
Highly Educated highly salaried and
unelected people at the United Nations
they have produced this compact that
will silence Free Speech media freedom
and if you think you're in control of
your borders think again this compact
backs the EU and the un's aim to flood
our nations with 59 million migrants by
2025 Yes you heard right 59 million
migrants by
2025 yes the clock is ticking it's all
is nearly 2019 just 6 years to go why
are they doing this I hear you ask
because in the year 2000 these numpties
came up with the idea that our
populations were declining and therefore
needed
replacing but how things have changed EU
unemployment is at a record high some
countries have 50% youth unemployment in
some areas of Greece it's even up to
75% most countries that have taken IM
migrants are finding they are
unemployable on average migrants have
133% unemployment have a 13% %
employment rate so are a burden on the
state even merkel's immigration spoken
spokesman said that up to 34s of IM
immigrants will still be unemployed in 5
years and for many others we need up to
10 years the statistics are long and
Grim voters in the UK yes you pay
attention Mrs May will sneak into maresh
to sign this dodgy deal just like golden
brown before her did when he sneaked
into to sign the Lisbon treaty no nice
group photo just her signature that
binds all of us to uncontrolled
immigration do you think that we're
taking back control of our borders in
her brexit Shambo deal think again
remember the UN and the globalists want
to flood our continent with 59 million
migrants by 2025 Mrs merco is sound on
this subject she says nation state
should be prepared to give up
sovereignty and it is nationalistic not
to sign so UK citizens did you think
that brexit means taking back control of
our sovereignty not with this gobl deal
as the document and the EU States
immigration is inevitable desirable and
necessary this is after we have poured
billions into Africa Africa is rich in
resources we should be encouraging them
to stay at home did you know that
Africa's population is 1.2 billion
Europe's is 741 million and did you know
that the UK Europe China India and Japan
combined could fit inside of Africa and
then there is the Middle Eastern
immigration these two continents pouring
into our countries is unsustainable in
the compact there is no provision for
how much this is going to cost the
infrastructure needed yet they bang on
about climate change sustainability and
overcrowding and there is the complete
absence of De Democratic deficit of this
compact no one asked the voters whether
we wanted this no one asked us if we
wanted our culture and identity crushed
and why because they know they would
never get this past the voters and then
there is the serious question of free
speech and how we've refer to migrants
refugees and Asylum seekers in their
eyes they're all one children will take
presidence sounds sensible not really
because it will encourage migrants to
people traffic their children for
eventual family
reunification we will not be allowed to
use the term migrants or illegal
migrants they all become irregular
migrants the media will be told what to
write and the language to be used social
media will also be controlled more than
they are already it will be illegal not
to use their prescribed language there
is a lot in this compact that needs to
be stopped so what can you do write
letters not emails to your elected
representatives we're not alone the US
Australia Israel Slovakia Austria
Bulgaria Poland Hungary the Czech
Republic are not signing more are
joining every day if we don't stop our
heads of state signing this document
then you can say goodbye to democracy
and your way of life get to action
people and get in touch with your heads
of states and stop this Global compact
being signed